hmm  oh don't don't something don't something  like a [ __ ] [ __ ] it was right it was  very time when I teased my relations  instead I changed my face  David you got it you got a key somewhere  else never got here no not a word or  I'll [ __ ] kill you  and failure  it was his huge what I loved was his  next haha  next next be really much to those yeah  can you hock a loogie  suitable demos sesame tempos scissor me  timbers me timbers  you're the shot  you  I dunno  did your [ __ ] Foley in the middle of  my monologue Oh  Oh  okay cool  that's like a spoon do okay so can we do  one like this and then one yes fine  right not all animals  okay how many were there before me not  63 you filthy-ass McNasty not 63 yah  filthy [ __ ] not 63 yeah  coochie monster not 63 yeah Turbo [ __ ]  not 63 just Lissy later on tonight I ask  you to be my girlfriend